et avec nous pour en parler olivier le
cour grandmaison politologue
universitaire auteur de l ouvrage ennemi
mortel représentation de l'islam et
politique musulmane en france à l'époque
coloniale aux éditions la découverte
bonjour je vous remercie d'être avec
nous est ce que vous partagez vous le
sentiment plutôt qu'est ce que vous
pensez de de ces déclarations de
stéphane martin l'ex président du musée
quai branly pour qui justement la
restitution d'oeuvres en afrique sont
incrits constituer un cri de haine
contre le concept même de musée je
trouve cette déclaration un peu
singulière il faut rappeler comme le
rapport saville sarlat d'ailleurs
mentionné de façon très précise qu' un
nombre extrêmement important d'oeuvres
d'art ont été effectivement et pillés au
cours de la conquête coloniale et de la
colonisation dont il faut rappeler qu'un
candidat à la présidence de la
république
emmanuel macron avait déclaré que la
colonisation était un crime contre
l'humanité
ce crime contre l'humanité n'a pas
seulement portée contre les personnes
assurément mais ce crime a eu aussi pour
conséquence le pillage de ce que nous
appelons des oeuvres d'art équipes sont
pas forcément dans les pays où elles ont
été pillées des oeuvres d'art mais
parfois des oeuvres religieuses en tout
cas assurément des oeuvres absolument
essentiel du patrimoine et de ce point
de vue là il me paraît tout à fait
légitime que les pays qui ont eu à subir
eux cela demande la restitution des
oeuvres ainsi spolier alors il ya
évidemment l'aspect historique
mais dans ce secret de stéphane martin
justement est-ce qu'il faut voir aussi
la question de la préservation des des
oeuvres parce que
les pays africains n'ont pas forcément
les moyens de deux d'exposer ses oeuvres
comme elles le sont dans les pays
européens
en france c'est un argument qui
effectivement est souvent avancé si les
pays concernés n'ont pas les moyens que
la france ou des institutions
internationales les aide à construire
effectivement les musées qui permettront
d'accueillir dans de bonnes conditions
ses oeuvres et qui permettront que parce
que c'est pas simplement accueillir dans
de bonnes conditions les neuf c'est
aussi accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions
celles et ceux qui vont de nouveau avoir
accès à ces oeuvres parce que rappelons
que par ceux là même que ces oeuvres ne
sont pas là bas mais ici et ont troqué
bon en ligne ça veut donc dire que les
citoyens de ces pays n'ont pas accès à
toute une partie du patrimoine
historique religieux et artistiques qui
est pourtant le leur et j'imagine que si
la situation était inverse les
gouvernements français quel qu'il soit
serait tout à fait
en pointe pour le dire ainsi mais pour
exiger la restitution d'oeuvres et qui
est considéré comme absolument essentiel
ou patrimoine national il ya aussi la
question du remplacement des oeuvres
dans les collections par exemple
s'agissant du dieu qui du musée quai
branly
ça c'est une question aussi qu'il faut
prendre en compte d'abord on peut faire
une image in des copies et d'autre part
que je sache il ya beaucoup
d'expositions qui ont lieu dans les
musées français qui sont des expositions
qui repose à la fois sur la présentation
d'oeuvres qui sont dans des musées
français mais aussi sur des oeuvres qui
sont prêtées par des institutions
nationales étrangères et ou par des
intrusions internationale et donc le
fait que ces oeuvres parts dans leur
pays d'origine de mon point de vue ne
l'interdît pas à l'avenir que le musée
du quai branly ou d'autres musées
demande au musée ou pour lesquelles ces
oeuvres ont été restitués de les prêter
pendant un moment pour l'organisation et
d'exposition temporaire puisque cela se
fait pour d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'expositions qui ont lieu en france
puisque vous êtes un spécialiste de la
colonisation
ce rapport savoir qui préconise de
rendre donc des dizaines de milliers
d'oeuvres acquises entre 1880 et 1960 au
pays subsahariens parce que c'est un
geste qui était un geste symbolique pour
justement réparer l'histoire cela
participe effectivement d'une part de la
reconnaissance des torts extrêmement
important infligées à ces pays et aux
populations et cela participe
effectivement d'une forme de
reconnaissance et de réparation
réparation symbolique réparation
politique et réparation matérielle par
ceux là mêmes effectivement que celles
et ceux qui ont été privés pendant des
dizaines
année de l'accès à ces oeuvres peuvent
lorsqu'elles seront restitués
effectivement de nouveau pouvoir
fréquenter les musées où ils pourront de
nouveau admirer les oeuvres de leur
patrimoine national l'enjeu pour les
pays africains qui sont concernés par
ces oeuvres c'est de pouvoir justement
reconstituer leur histoire nationale au
gouvernement qu aujourd'hui s'est
reconstitué une partie de l'histoire
nationale en sachant que ces oeuvres
sont en général été pillé dans des
circonstances où il n'y avait pas d'état
nation et dans les régions concernées il
n'en reste pas moins que ces oeuvres
effectivement sont aujourd'hui perçus
comme appartenant au patrimoine national
d'état devenus indépendants et qu'à ce
titre il me paraît une fois encore
parfaitement légitime qui s'est étalée
réclament aujourd'hui les cpi justement
subsahariens qui qui prône
l'indépendance et l'indépendance
économique l'indépendance tout court
mais l'indépendance culturelle aussi
c'est important
alors l'indépendance culturelle c'est
évidemment un très important de mon
point de vue elle ne va évidemment pas
sans une certaine indépendance
économique et financière d'où la
question du franc cfa qui a été posée eu
dernièrement notamment par le président
emmanuel macron et la suite justement
vous qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez
justement qu'on avance encore plus qu'on
aille encore plus loin
je crois que le rapport savant du sort
et de ce point de vue là assez
remarquable en tout cas par rapport à la
situation antérieure où il y avait un
blocage très cynique est significatif à
la fois des autorités politiques
françaises et les directions des musées
et donc je pense que ce qui a été établi
et couché sur le papier dans le rapport
sur la volt star doit être effectivement
appliqué il faut aller faire de la
coopération culturelle et bien sûr aller
vers la coopération culturelle dont
considérant que la restitution de ces
oeuvres encore une fois est légitime et
juste et qu'elle n'empêchera pas à
l'avenir des institutions muséales
françaises de les présenter
si tel est leur bon plaisir et si tel
est leur souhait merci beaucoup
olivier lacour le koura grandmaison je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue
universitaire auteur de l'ouvragé ennemi
mortel représentation de l'islam et
politique musulmane en france à l'époque
coloniale aux éditions est la découverte
merci à vous donc c